how is your band by the way you would've
actually been playing together I know
I've been checking out your music can we
expect another album there's an EP
coming out on Black Friday
do you like the other guys in the band
are you like the Beatles in the sense
that you guys had your battles yes sir
you know we kind of didn't really see
each other for a lot of years why was
that you got involved in comedy we just
lived our lives we went on you know yeah
Peter Swan he moved to Arizona he became
a judge yeah your band this was when you
were in high school you started this is
yeah this was we didn't even play live
we were sort of an experimental band
once guy is a professor of Czech
literature I read that's right why
you've done your research yes what happy
I think the University of London writers
ooh see and and Chris who's sort of the
brains and sort of like the musical
heart and soul the man he lives in
Brooklyn and he sells futures and he's a
successful guy yeah and and we and when
you call these guys out of the blue
after many years and say look I'm
thinking of getting the band back
together it wasn't my idea whose idea
was it it was the album that we recorded
roadkill
yes roadkill which everyone knows yeah
was was discovered by a record company
called captured tracks which I guess is
an outsider music label so in other
words now that you are famous maybe we
can get a couple of minutes to buy this
apparently not apparently that it was
appreciated on its own merits before
they knew that I was the drummer and I
don't know and when did the band form
and you were in high school yeah I
formed in 1982 and broke up in 1982 and
it wasn't gene Simmons involved at one
point you you had a friend she Chris's
parents knew gene Simmons and you
brought him the album yeah Chris's mom
invited Gene Simmons to have dinner with
us right and and he and this was like
you know this is like at the height of
kiss right and were you a kiss fan I was
sort of it not really but he's a guy in
the business and you could yeah there's
also gene Simmons I mean you know it's
like there's a you know you know it was
like to see him out of makeup was insane
it was very amazing yeah and he had
dinner with us
talk to us and and yeah he was he was
nice to us did he support the band or
did was there any advice given he I
don't really remember that much I know
that he Nightcrawler knows that no kiss
album Nightcrawler night something and
these creatures of the night creatures
of the night in the night yeah yeah so
Chris had a song called creatures of the
night and oh and then that ended up
being the name of a cold edition are you
accusing yeah I'm not I'm accusing kiss
of anything I'm just your band was
capital punishment you're saying are you
gonna go to court over this that you
have to talk to Chris about it because
Chris feels that something happened
there are you now in touch with the band
I mean are you guys bonding and so what
happened was they they actually wanted
to put the album at that we recorded in
1982 so I was like alright fine
and then Chris said you know maybe we
should get together because they might
want to do a thing like where we play
together live or something my favorite
track is when someone is breathing and
saying the word John don't over and over
and this is very heavy yeah listen to
this you guys were way ahead of your
time he's breathing a very dark al John
[Laughter]
it's just weird to listen to something
that you did 35 years ago and it's still
around yeah I would come to a concert a
few guys performed well we're actually
I'm enjoying playing with the guys it's
actually been fun it's therapeutic and
essentially could you yeah because it's
not serious at all it's not you know
something I actually look at it
something I would you know
affectionately do but yet it's really
fun yeah